new at six could we soon see the end of
Resort fees this week the White House
says it's working to do just that
President Biden says this week that he's
taking aim in Hidden junk fees including
those that are charged at strip Resorts
Sasha loft is joining us now live in the
Las Vegas Strip with what this means for
tourists and the next time you stay in a
hotel Sasha
Denise and Brian those I spoke with here
on the Strip say they love the idea of
no resort fees a lot of tourists
actually told me it would change the way
they book vacations if this were to
happen now this discussion comes after
President Biden shared a plan this week
to crack down on things like Resort fees
by ordering the Federal Trade Commission
to investigate here in Las Vegas the
majority of strip Resorts charge an
average Resort fee of about 40 bucks a
night local experts say if this change
is made Resorts would likely just raise
their rates but many we spoke with
believe upfront pricing would still be
better
I think it'll provide more transparency
in pricing which is usually a good thing
and it'll just give people a better idea
of exactly what they're getting into
when they go to book they sell you the
eight dollars a night or twenty dollars
a night and it's all by the way you got
the resort fee
the President also says it his
administration would Target quote hidden
fees on concert and airline tickets even
Bank overdraft fees now last week the
Federal Trade Commission voted to begin
a rule process to prevent these quote
junk fees but no word on when or if they
would take effect rather here in Las
Vegas reporting live on this trip
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now